[Musica]
allora faccio una premessa io sono una
persona molto ansiosa chiedevo a dirlo
prima di iniziare quindi vi assicuro che
già avere adesso davanti a me un timer
countdown qui davanti che sa molto di
spazio ma invece in realtà sa molto di
ansia non mi mette molto a mio agio ma è
giusto così perché le cose vanno fatte
bene con ordine e partiamo anche dal
principio che è fondamentalmente un uomo
intendo un uomo maschio non è abituato
che gli venga detto vai veloce
ne approfitto della mia ragazza che mi
starà pensando questo momento ma detto
questo io vorrei oggi farvi arrivare un
messaggio pro per farlo faccio un
passetto indietro e vi dico questa cosa
ci ha ucciso questa frase video killed
the radio stars diceva una famosissima
canzone the buggles ecco eppure mi
sembra che nonostante tutto oggi noi in
macchina con gli amici in cameretta o
magari mentre facciamo la doccia
magari uno sotto l'acqua propostagli a
fianco ascoltiamo la radio non lo
facciamo più magari con la vecchia radio
però qualche in piattaforma digitale
adesso ci sono i libri di tipo club
house di una radio ma dove vuoi anche
villa tua da da spettatore c'è qualcuno
che parla sopra tour
anzi la manina e dici la tua addirittura
esistono le messe le messe
fate su che base chiama la cappella di
club house veramente ho controllato ieri
è bellissimo
i fedeli alza la mano e dicono amen
pensate un po dove siamo arrivati e
bellezza è stata se ci pensate
in particolare quindi vedete ecco
diciamo che la tecnologia ci ha sempre
spaventato
tutto ciò che è nuovo a questo che è che
è sconosciuto ci ha sempre messo un po
d'ansia
questo perché perché non sappiamo cos'è
ma vale per tante cose anche per le cose
diverse
sì ecco diverso il caso di vaughan
procure tematiche di cui si parla a
volte le tematiche razziali che quelle
tematiche che se ne parli con amy ci
fanno ma ti pare davvero no ma non è più
così ma io ti trovo un amico che no
invece in alcune case per esempio molte
si sente ancora di alcune cose o
quell'odore di medievale no
e poi siamo costretti a portare dei
ragazzi su tik tok a spiegarci cose con
dei balletti magari non lo capisce a
parole magari si muovono le braccia face
che ci arrivano nome tranquilli non
voglio farvi un discorso sulla politica
non voglio attaccarmi delle cose
no c'è gente più importante più illustri
e può parlare di questo in altre sedi
darebbero libro parla chiunque parla ma
a parte questo io voglio oggi parlarvi
di futuro che cos'è il futuro se non la
diretta rappresentanza rappresentazione
di come abbiamo speso il nostro presente
non ditelo dettaglio perché se no non è
un importante ogni giorno più tosta cosa
ha effetto marco esattamente il futuro
noi siamo siamo spaventati dal futuro
sempre saputo mete spaventati di noi ci
porterà l'avvento della tecnologia di
queste novità che non ci concentriamo a
usarle al meglio qui e adesso sui social
e col meglio non intendo l'orto virtuale
su un farmville
no anche se mi rendo conto che l'unico
posto dove non ci marciscono le zucchine
o le banane stati mai fatto caso di
quanto è difficile non far rovinare le
banane certo le compri verdi al
supermercato tempo che arrivi a casa
sono già gialle sembrerebbe perché le
menti vicina le mele le mele hanno una
sorta di ormone che fa maturare prima ma
perché dovresti mettere le banane
affianca alle mele e pure brutto da
vedere su un piatto su una forma carina
con questo divagando sto divagando io
voglio di una cosa che non possiamo non
dire che questo momento storico è stato
salvato dalla tecnologia dai social che
vuoi immaginatevi il lock down senza i
post e selphy una videochiamata una
diretta di alcune di volere avremmo
fatto a meno però comunque sua foto e
così via
immaginate quanto è stato importante
mangiare ma è stato importante per
alcune persone poter poter vedere un
parente un fidanzato da lontano e per
parenti non intendo quello zio che
vediamo soltanto a natale quello che
dicono niente fondamentalmente che ci
regala sempre stesso paio di calzini
tutti gli anni una sciarpa un cappello
dei guanti sempre quelli sempre lo
stesso tipo e puntualmente non ho mai
cercato perché perché pensano che noi ci
immagina come se lo stesso con mezzo a
un campo che non deve e non ci devono
coprire qualche in maniera molto chiara
questa cosa ma è così è vero oppure
immaginate quanto possano essere stato
fondamentale quella cenetta in
videochiamata con il fidanzato o quella
ceretta con l'amica in videochiamata
scene tipo guarda allora visto questa
serie bellissima nuova da devo spiegare
al successo che ho e spoiler per otto
dico è numero libero se spoiler non l'ha
proprio perché ci tengo noi abbiamo
condivide ma non condividiamo sarà si
spiega secondo vita
la striscia che poi non ho mai capito
perché le mie amiche siete pilastro
durante lock down
non ho mai capito ma volete voi un perno
dei discorsi finisco male ai conventi
verso vedere quello che vuoi farmi
capire che tutto quanto all'inizio
appena stato creato che la un fine
nobile anche la plastica soprattutto ma
anche la carta cioè che quando hanno
inventato la plastica è un'idea la
plastica interessante ci facciamo delle
bottiglie
bella bella idea quale buttiamo a mare
senso noi facciamo ma prima dei tempi a
mona no e buttiamo a voi la carta cos'è
la carta cellulosa miscugli un po tutto
quanto poi ci facciamo impacchettiamo
così ma non la paghiamo la buttiamo per
terra come l'abuso werther voce ha senso
ecco non è che è andata proprio così
c'era sempre un fine nobile cioè le
buone intenzioni
purtroppo poi vengono sopraffatte dalla
maleducazione
sì lo so che appena uno dice così in
testa riparte subito a na na na na na na
na na na euro morgan è dietro l'angolo
si ma ne hanno contati perdoni per
questa brutta citazione così ecco questo
per farvi capire cioè ok mi spiego da
che voglio arrivare sarò più e non lo
voglio abbandonare questo paese non lo
voglio abbandonare ok per quadrante
ragazzi è un cane che si morde la coda
perché le stesse persone che si
lamentano che l'aria troppo inquinata
sono le stesse può che prendono la
macchina anche per fare un metro e mezzo
oppure quelli che si lamentano che c'è
poca acqua lo sai che in california
l'acqua non c'è più la prendo un'altra
da altre nazioni ma anche in italia in
alcuni posti forse non lo sapete ma è
così ma la cosa non gli stessi che
stanno sette ore sotto la doccia a farsi
quell'interminabile dolce caldissima
riflettere sulla loro vita ma perché non
lo fate un altra parte no sotto la
doccia posta gli devi cantare vi fa il
tuo sanremo personale tanto non ti ci
mettono a sanremo anche ho fatto molti
sanremo sotto la voce vincevo sempre
comunque a parte questo ecco mi sono
perso
volevo dirvi io la realtà è che non ci
voglio andare su marte non la prendete
come un brutto messaggio però
e lontano molto lontano
ragazzi ma state già la luna dove sta
invece vediamo sulla luna io delle
amiche lunatiche immaginatevi se li
porti sulla luna cosa può succedere che
facciamo qui costruiamo delle cose poi
da lì ce la andiamo da un'altra parte
oggi ho scoperto che c'è la monnezza
dello spazio l'immondizia perché non
avesse capito ma io potevo pensare a
cosa del genere
l'immondizia nello spazio che galleggia
tra immaginate a casa mia non riescono
ancora a raccogliere separatamente la
differenziata
immaginatevi quelli della ma nello
spazio che vanno in giro così a cercare
i sacchetti dove pensiamo di andare fino
alla giu che fai
andiamo verso marte facciamo un pit stop
di modo grave sulla luna ci fermiamo un
attimo poi prendiamo andiamo dice su
marte
perché perché è lontanissimo a me mi va
in panne la macchina sulla salerno
reggio calabria figuriamo semina morte
cosa potrebbe mai succedere ma potrebbe
colpirti un asteroide ma però cavolo
e non è che li fai a una strana idea e
esci dal finestrino no l'abbiamo visto
cosa succede
tutti abbiamo visto interstellar giri
all'infinito non ti fermi mai è orribile
perché non ti fermi mai non c'è la non
c'è nessuna forza di spingere battere
starnutisce uno spazio e arrivi non lo
so su saturno renda e poi immaginatevi
che sono già allergico al nichel
figuriamoci su marte dopo la polvere
rossa a tutto rosso sarà ma andiamo su
marte perché cerchiamo l'atmosfera ma
che prospera vuoi fare su marte
almeno 60 amore ti piace questa
atmosfera
no vabbè ma torniamo ci prendiamo che
giove no marketing ragazzi scusate a
questo punto se tanto ci piace marte
andiamo a lanzarote è uguale identica
alle canarie pacchettino ibiza seba
malinteso allora è meglio mi sembri a
scavare fare se facciamo un buco così è
simile a come potrebbe essere il buco la
volta ci entra dentro tutta torino ma
chi se ne frega la perché non alias come
gli stagni buchi pensate vi in ottavi
notato su martin o quel buco non si
parlo dico no qua non ci dà paschi è che
fai crimine che scrive elio lo immagino
già qualcuno qua quando si rivelano devo
capire se possiamo starci prova la
rimette in un cubo di ghiaccio che lo
cura di ghiaccio as much as congelare i
gamberetti perché non chiudo il freezer
di magia dentro il ghiaccio amore ha
chiuso la porta della cella termica
porca miseria e purtroppo sono scordato
ai congelato nonna vero l'ho lasciata lì
su lucio la fata prato o di mia suocera
no non è ma che c'entra non l'ho fatto
apposta rimasta lì aver trovato
suvvia un po s abbiamo coltivato i
fagiolini questa settimana ma da ragazzi
lo immaginate con l'ansia sul ghiaccio
intorno esci mi dimentico le chiavi per
poter mai ricordarmi di chiudere il
casco al resto come muoiono e orrendo
atto di forza e le mani stowe si gonfia
esplora una cosa bruttissima
non mi sembra il caso lanzarote canarie
caldo è lì un po così ma questo perché i
ragazzi è una parte gli scherzi eco ci
facciamo una cosa facciamo un gioco
bellissimo lungo da portare avanti
all'infinito
diamoci bene il nostro pianeta facendo
una cosa ogni volta che ci capita
qualcosa di nuovo beauty ed innovativo
chiudiamo gli occhi e diciamo dentro di
noi come un mantra questa cosa molto
bella molto utile ma dei pro e dei
contro come posso utilizzarla al meglio
senza fare del male a me stesso e gli
altri ti amo da somme e via e così
all'infinito
ripensate e rimaniamo qui e lì ci
mandiamo che ci sta antipatico prevedere
marte raccontami come mai ci riuniamo fa
18 a li sentiamo si è mi raccomando eh
oppure in luna di miele no no qui ok
ragazzi
volendo davvero c'è sempre marte ci
possiamo andare andiamoci speriamo solo
di stare simpatici agli omini verdi
grazie
[Applauso]